what's up everyone welcome back to the
supper suite for another Tiff 2022
interview with the team behind the
swearing jar congratulations I love your
movie give me the soundtrack to own and
listen to over it I know right she's
amazing we're gonna get to your singing
in a minute but because this is a
festival Premiere some of our viewers
will not know what your movie is just
yet so would you mind doing the honors
and giving a brief description of the
swearing jar oh my gosh I'm horrible at
this I feel like you might be better
uh it's do you want to try
it's a story about a woman and her
marriage and you know the ins and at the
outs and the
the ways that things unravel and it's
about
forgiveness and moving on and Redemption
and all of those things
together you don't have an easy job
describing this movie because things
happen that are really significant we're
not going to spoil anything here but
things happen that are very significant
so I feel like what you just did was the
perfect tease I tried it's difficult so
this movie is based on a play correct
yeah
um what is what is something about
adapting it to screen that you think
brought something out of the story that
the stage couldn't but then also what is
something about adapting a stage play
that I guess makes it like difficult to
make it cinematic yeah it was really for
me it was really interesting I like
asked Kate if she had a if had filmed a
version of the cake oh yeah Kate's the
writer you're great at this
um and she unfortunately didn't and so I
was because I was really interested to
see how the stage play did it um and how
I was going to do it or how we were
going to do it and I think from play to
movie
um
the main like I really focused in my
what I tried to do was really focus in
on Carrie and her journey and like
really put the film in her perspective
and as you shift through things
um you're really experiencing it with
her which I think can only really be
done in that Medium I think that would
be quite difficult in a play form
um so
I think it's a really interesting
adaption uh Kate's very pleased and this
one is absolutely incredible in the film
so Kate wrote the play and she wrote the
screenplay yeah why do you think it was
important and maybe better off that the
original writer was also the
screenwriter
because it's her baby yeah she knew the
story in and out and she said last night
um there were more characters in the
play
um and then in the screenplay that I'm
just sort of um
representing her here but yeah she said
that um she that she kind of focused on
on the principal role of Kerry that way
in film you can kind of be up close with
that character and experience what
they're going through but I think also
with the music you know it it's it's uh
it was a play with music in it and
um it's not necessarily like it doesn't
feel like a musical like a classical
musical it feels more akin to something
like once
um where music is such a part of the
character's lives and so
um I think in film as well you have the
ability to kind of overlap and you're
not moving from musical number to scene
so much that they're kind of all
um they layer and yeah it's incredibly
organic and one of the other reasons why
I really want to own the soundtrack
because nothing excites me more than
when I take uh Movie music and I take it
on the go and I listen to it and it can
bring me right back to the scene that it
corresponds to and I just have very high
hopes that that's going to have up in
here let's just talk about the music I'm
sorry you don't you hadn't sung before
or did you not know you were as good as
you are in this movie I was reading in
the notes that like you had never done
this before and I can't compute that no
I've never done this I mean of course
we'll sing well yeah you know like I I
sing by myself but I didn't really have
the confidence to um
I I don't know it's it's a very
different thing like your relationship
with your voice on your own is very
different to your from you know a
relationship with your voice and and
people seeing it um or hearing it and
yeah so I just like got this audition
and I wasn't sure what they wanted
um and so I just recorded myself singing
a Leonard Cohen song If it was Chelsea
Hotel and
um and then beautiful I took some
serious lessons and yeah and here we are
oh my God like I don't want to say this
because I want you to like active movies
all the time because that's what I focus
on but like you can legit have like a
whole nother career because seriously
you're you're singing is incredible
really sweet heavy you can't wait for
your album to drop I mean honestly I
would sit here and wait for that if you
said you would do it having I think the
note said you worked with two uh singing
coaches for this right yeah I work with
two different singing coaches that I got
um referred to through friends and
um I just I did like a vocal warm-up for
an hour every day and that is so fun and
amazing
um and yeah and then and then I was so
lucky that we had um Tim Williams who
was our composer who's so experienced
and he really like I'd never recorded in
a studio before so that first like day
and a half
um I I just did not know like I was like
um it like it's it's a it's a technique
I'd never like practiced before and he
was really helpful having studied with
um singing coaches is there anything
about what that taught you about what
you can do with your voice that you're
able to apply to either voice acting or
just any form of acting in general oh
yeah I mean
I I'm I'm so like I like the science
part of it so I was like yeah I mean I
could go on for hours about like I had
this incredible teacher um Erica who
just like took me through you know how
to how to uh move between the different
ranges and you know where yeah
amazing that's so fascinates me because
I admire singing so much and like I know
music like I I know when something is on
key but I can't physically like make my
voice do that so that but you can't you
can like it's it's it's it's it's like
you don't know me or my singing voice
very well but yeah I I feel like I
should study one day and actually learn
um and you you did the the singing live
on set even though you recorded some
elements in a studio right
yeah yeah she it was yeah I can't fully
remember but yeah we you were saying
yeah it's a microphone yeah we had we
had the music you know and then we
worked with the guitarist and we
rehearsed for a week with Douglas myself
Tim and this incredible guitarist Justin
and then and you know we were sort of
establishing the songs establishing the
tempo you know what like the songs from
the musical you know in in film we
changed Tempo we change pitch you know
pitch and things like that and then um
once we had the we had the songs
established then we could take that into
filming I mean it's it's complicated but
it was really really fun and then we had
the option to use the live version or or
the studio recording always good to have
as many options as you can yeah and we
kind of remember between the two when we
were mixing this because I liked a lot
of the live stuff like you know and I
was like yeah I know
but it was really beautiful so I I
worked with him to like when we were
putting the the songs actually together
mixing the songs it was like I was we
were oscillating between the two
performances because I mean you were
incredible in both but there was
something really for me about the live
stuff that was nice and raw um and the
pre-recorded stuff you know it was it
was more controlled yeah
I think what you settled on is Pitch
Perfect
um so Adelaide obviously we have the
singing One Challenge you have to be
able to sell your characters inner
turmoil without explaining everything
there's there's like the jumping of
timelines when you first signed on for
this movie is there anything you circled
as being like the most difficult
challenge for you and then ultimately
was that the most challenging thing or
did something else Catch You by surprise
it's not a challenge when you're doing
work that you're so excited to do I know
that sounds really corny but like the
writing was the writing was so strong
and great and I trusted it and then I
was so excited to meet Lindsay and
immediately like we pretty quickly I was
I recognized that we communicate really
well and we kind of speak the same
language and then and then you know you
have that shorthand especially like in
independent film when you're doing the
hours in the day you know and in a lot
of the film it's so important that we
had that shorthand and we have the same
taste yeah you know so important that's
really hot like you it's really rare to
find that
um and and then yeah I mean you know the
moving through time I don't I really
don't want to give anything away about
the story because you know I want an
audience to experience uh this film as
we read it and and
um and as you saw it and I think it's
it's really important that they they
don't know what the you can use the word
twist or reveal whatever it is
um because it's part of the storytelling
like the structure Kate's structure
is is
um it's also it's telling us about the
character about the character's state of
mind
um and it's giving us her perspective on
the situations that she's dealing with
and I just think I I haven't seen us
um I haven't seen a story that has
commentary on these challenges in the
way that this film does so I feel like I
know exactly what you mean yeah it's
like so cryptic but what what you're
being cryptic about is done quite
beautifully and that's not an easy thing
to achieve in a film I promise you it's
worth it don't don't read the review I I
will yeah please don't read reviews
um I will just emphasize that it's very
good um I love hearing about the magic
that happens when you're on set that you
can't expect so even with all the prep
you likely did for this movie is there
any particular scene that didn't come to
life until you were physically on set
filming it
for me it was the scene with Douglas in
uh
the living room
because I feel like that was the first
time we ever really got that scene on
its feet with
um with uh Matilda yeah with Matilda
yeah
it was yeah you guys it was so beautiful
like and I remember I was I was behind
camera
and we we did one take and we finished
it I think we were on you we finished it
and both Jordan the cinematographer and
I looked at each other and we were like
oh wow
let's go again
it was really yeah I mean there were a
lot of those on set because because we
didn't have much rehearsal time it was
to see you guys bring scenes to life was
just so everyone was so instinctual and
so
lovely it was really it was a joy yeah I
mean I want like we did we had we had
one day of rehearsal before we went in
and there was there was a scene that um
originally we had kind of pictured in
the living room as a pinnacle scene
um between uh Patrick and my character
and
um uh I mean that that was amazing that
was really interesting because in the
space I kind of like we're coming home
and I was like I go to the kitchen
you know like everyone just got you as
well I I go to the kitchen that's where
I put my bag and that's where I settle
home and and it changed the scene
because suddenly we weren't in this
expansive living room we were in a
cramped kitchen and we kind of were
forced to be in the same space together
and and it and it's a difficult scene so
um things like that like the house was
so much a part of the story
um the production designer Diana was
incredible incredible and you know when
you have all these talented people
together it's it Things fall into place
in and yeah it's awesome it's awesome so
many follow-ups bringing up the
production design is there any like
little corner of the house production
design that you could tease where it's a
smaller detail that maybe isn't focused
on heavily in camera but it speaks to
you know their history together and
where they're at when we first meet them
in the movie
oh my gosh
books everywhere there was yeah there
was Arts there was
and little changes that she made when
yeah the the house is its own story too
like it goes through
yeah the bed you know the with the bed
meant and and how it held like it had
yeah I mean I feel so bad asking you
guys I know it's so hard
um here's another question I feel bad
asking because I feel like I should be
posing it to Douglas but one thing that
really caught me in this story was just
like Owen's perspective on everything
there's just one line after the next
where I'm like let me write that line
down and take it with me so what do you
think it is about him as a person and
his past that I don't know gave him that
kind of awareness and understanding when
we see him in the movie
oh my gosh okay yo you've got a great I
put a lot of thought into that so I
wanted to know your take
I mean I like okay for me I I feel like
um
I feel like Carrie is is is is imperfect
she's dealing
um she's
made a decision at some point
subconsciously or not to like to engage
with denial and just and I think I I
think a lot of parents can can probably
relate to it
um but but she's she's Delta really uh
challenging deck of cards and she
um is just coping she's just coping and
I think Owen comes along and he is
he's kind of comfortable being imperfect
and that is what gives her permission to
then
you know and look at herself and it and
he kind of holds up a mirror to her in a
way all right I'm gonna have to let you
guys go soon but just to highlight some
of your other incredible co-stars here
who which two people would you say have
the most unique way of approaching their
work where when you're their scene
partner you know you're going to get a
completely different experience acting
on set
even when I'm not teasing spoilers it's
still difficult I mean
Douglas was perfect for Owen when we met
him we were like whoa yeah
what like
I did did Kate know him before she wrote
this and then Patrick was so he was so
grounded and surprising and he's so
experienced and
um and he really kind of got it he was
you know he just kind of took charge in
a way that was so
liberating for me
um and I think we needed that in Simon
we really needed someone with a lot of
kind of Gravitas and then of course
Kathleen is just I mean you're like so
fortunate to have worked with her and
she was she's so experienced she's so
fun she loves film she loves filmmaking
she loves acting it was
everybody everybody wanted to be there
you know and that that's
pretty special yeah it was very special
it's one of the most important things on
any set out there before I let you go
one last question if you two had a
swearing jar which bad word would have
you adding the most money to that jar
and you can use the bad word now it is
okay
mine would be [ __ ]
excellent choice
I feel like you're you're not you don't
swear very much I I tend to yeah yeah I
don't know I I just make noises in and
she's just very over exaggerated
Australian accent
example
yeah
[ __ ] yes that's it that's the one all
right I will take that
congratulations on your movie I meant
everything I said it is wonderful and I
I want a soundtrack like that's that's
actually I do take a comment that is a
demand I want a soundtrack as a record
that would be incredible wouldn't it you
should talk to whoever like Wax works
there could be some like because you
have a good poster for this movie I feel
like there's some really creative
artwork that can be done on that it's
just so sweet Bring it on I love it
thank you so much everybody out there
keep an eye out for the swearing jar
thank you see you with more
conversations at the supper Suite soon